[Music]
kanye west wants kim kardashian back and
he's letting it be known with song
just something from my heart on thursday
during the free larry hoover benefit
concert with drake the 44 year old
rapper performed his hit run away
run away
but he changed up the lyrics to shout
out his ex
[Music]
the grammy winner's estranged wife was
in the audience along with their
eight-year-old daughter northwest kim's
mom kris jenner and her boyfriend corey
gamble also in attendance at the la
memorial coliseum in l.a lizzo machine
gun kelly megan fox tyler the creator
offset chance the rapper and g-eazy
[Music]
of course the kkw beauty founder filed
for divorce from kanye in february and
this isn't the first time he's expressed
his desire to reconcile with the mother
of his four children i want to pull my
family back together last month yay
appeared on the podcast drink champs and
opened up about his impending divorce
from the 41 year old reality star
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want their parents i want us
to be together but if you want to be
together too if you look at the media
that's not what they promoting
that's not what they want they want it
to be a new wedding a new episode a new
tv show and then they have people all
around and my wife here you know there's
a publicist that's next to her i don't
[ __ ] with her and despite all that the
two have seemingly remained on good
terms since their split i always believe
and trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart back in august
kim came out dressed in a balenciaga
wedding gown during kanye's donda
listening event in chicago
he's done miracles on me
last month the two reunited to pay their
respects to the late virgil ablo at his
final louis vuitton show in miami and
earlier this week kim gave a special
shout out to her ex
you know to kanye even for
really introducing me to the fashion
world
i'm so humbled i'm just extremely happy
can you tell by my face
of course all this comes amid kim's
budding romance with pete davidson
it's a different experience for sure the
two first sparked romance rumors in
october after kim's appearance hosting
snl where she made jokes about her split
from kanye
when i divorced him you have to know it
came down to just one thing
his personality
i know that sounds mean but people keep
telling me that comedy comes from truth
and if there's one thing that i always
strive to be it's genuine since then the
two have been spotted on dates in his
hometown staten island snapped selfies
with a tourist during a beverly hills
outing rocked matching skims pajamas on
pete's birthday and were seen holding
hands on a roller coaster
i love that and while a source
previously told et the two are 100
dating and having a great time together
a second source said kim is also trying
to be sensitive toward kanye quote kim
has been protective of kanye and his
feelings and has been trying to keep her
hangouts with pete low key because she
doesn't know how he will react
[Music]
you